what are our favorite Nintendo
franchises because we were just talking
was a good segue we're talking about we
would love to see Nintendo focus on
games again which it doesn't seem like
they have been but at least they're
launching with Zelda it's one that we've
played and seems really fun so far
obviously Zelda is an easy place to
start I've been replaying I just beat
Majora's Mask 3d again on the Nintendo
3ds I'd be ocarina over break I played
both of those once a year I try to and
now I'm playing through win waker HD
just in between everything else I kind
of try to play zelda throughout the year
it's what you have a place my word store
this year no not yet this year it's
january nineteen eighteen yeah dude
clock's tickin all right I'll try to
play one Zelda a week did you do like
Skyward Sword I do I hate the
introduction to that game the first two
hours of the most boring two hours of
Zelda I've ever we're talking about
Skyward Sword right yes okay so I the
princess doesn't have a fun I neither
neither winwaker no but skyward sword is
like have you played a video game before
let me tell you what a sword is it's a
thing that can cut enemies my press the
a button is swing it with your arm fee
your guide fee fie I think feed diverse
on whatever yeah she tells you how to
solve puzzles throughout the game yeah I
don't like her okay I actually like
scouts were more than most people I'm
not just trying to dog yeah but I don't
like feat she tells you like oh maybe if
you put this electric ball in that
socket it'll power it like sweet fee
thanks a game games got flaws if I
wanted a built-in strategy guide i would
have built in a strategy guide i was
making that game that was my first
assignment gamespot was writing the the
game guide for scars really really was a
dungeon that gave a really good the one
where you have to tablet up in the first
section it's like a grid and you're
rearranging the rooms to fit them yeah
that was really fun dungeon in general
that game is actually really
well-designed and i like the flying a
lot as opposed to the sailing winwaker
which I like but I didn't weren't run by
the motion controls I kinda like them no
the wii motionplus it felt good yeah I
don't like the art style whoa I really
don't like the watercolor distance
background I feel I think it's just
Zelda's facelet and like links face I
don't like their faces and that's so
weird I'm like soda totally like tune
link loyalists a lip tune like really my
life
but I just that's the that's the one
thing I couldn't couldn't get behind
that's fair for real I don't know why I
think it's totally not a popular opinion
and just don't like it dreamy buzzell
did it look a little weird yeah right
yeah so is winwaker your favorite Zelda
um no my favorites all does majora's
mask yeah he what's yours ah link to the
past guess what mine is I don't know
Mike Majora's Mask yeah okay I always
have to separate if you're doing 2d
zelda vs 3 t's all it cuz i think they
are a little bit different so link to
the past is always my runner-up choice
because i love that one Wilson I think
link to the past is as close to perfect
as a game I've played yeah I'm not a
critic or anything now your honor what
do you think about like what do you
think what were digging into this we're
in telling talk about sure go for it
okay i think the game like totally
nailed like immediately the presentation
how you brought it into the story right
like your uncle goes out to like solve
some [ __ ] you find him and he's dying
like but take this sword you need to do
some stuff and save the princess like
all right it's dark and stormy night
you're like down in the dungeons doing
stuff like you rescue the princess like
it all just builds up so fast and then
your left essentially in an open world
right and it has a typical zelda /
metroid thing where you got a fine items
to progress and look for new things but
you have a lot of opportunity to scour
the environment for interesting stuff so
then you get to a certain point and what
do you know you can change the game and
flip it on his head and go to like a
Dark Dimension version of the world
awesome you know I love that when games
do that simply than I did it really well
but Link to the Past did at best first
and it's just a great progression of
skills and abilities and equipment
collating to a final battle Gannon I was
pretty cool yeah twitchy sure Gorman was
saying link between worlds is actually
really quite good and I agree speaking
of Link to the Past I think those games
are so similar in the way they're
structured overall well that's false
false objectively false yes I just said
similarly structured Mike you do what
you like you to know we go to a mirror
way what's trucks are we talking about
here because the link between worlds you
literally by the I to rent the item okay
okay I mean in
terms of i understand i played both
games a lot okay between worlds real
zelda by the items you get you rent the
items from whatever his name is and then
after a while you can buy them and when
you die you lose them if you have not
bought them I'm talking about just the
whole second half of the game is in a
dark world sure what I'm saying this
nonsense you're saying please don't
interrupt you meant somatically then no
it's automatically link between world is
more about the existential dread of
being again a character in a game
whereas Link to the Past is more about
like are any of us really like permanent
beings no we're not maybe there's a dark
world in all of us you want to talk
about you want talk about Van
wellesbourne you angry sometimes when
ppl causal link between worlds I could
not stand the I like to like the general
art style but whenever it did the like
the 2d I'm art moving along a wall where
we were rolling b-roll when you just did
that John Lewis miss my dance he do it
again when you're doing what that thing
we're gonna like shifting around a wall
yeah there we go okay um but yeah I no
longer like link between worlds after
seeing what you say you're always gonna
sound dumb asses do link between worlds
is one of the best zelda games Ravi oh
that's his name oh yeah oh yes red no
it's a great game but it's no link to
the past sound I had said I just said
they're similar in structure you anyway
um it was implied majora's mask is my
favorite by far it's my favorite game I
really love Majora's Mask mm-hmm I when
it came out on 3ds I went to the
midnight release and then I played it
like for a week straight so much that my
eyes hurt and I hadn't done that in
years you're the person that that
warning is for yes why they saying Oh
every Nintendo game is like like the
newer ones are like you should take a
break like I'm the person that's for
like get out of my way I want you
playing and I was like I'm one hundred
percent ignis and I might die doing it
yeah leave me alone uh you won't even
have a trophy to show for it I know I
literally took a picture of the you
talked to the kid and he's like I have
nothing left to tell you or whatever he
says and I was like yes I've done it
this is my achievement I'm seeing just X
kaz in the YouTube chat has said several
times ocarina is better than Majora's
Mask about like a year ago I would have
a
read and it probably is better but I
like Majora's Mask more I think Majora's
Mask is super weird and bold especially
considering the fact they were riding on
the coattails of Ocarina which
established like 3d adventure tropes now
but at the time we're really novel
Majora's Mask following up on it like
how super we're was you look at the boss
fighter now here's a guy org fish-faced
guy ordered a guy org you saw Dawa
before that here's a goat Kelly you're
saying is one of your favorite boss but
I really I just have a lot of fun with
go I mean like so when I say it's my
favorite Zelda that's more of a like
personal thing than active credit I mean
I don't think there's total objective it
has serious flaws but um I just love it
matically so much i love the dark angle
um I love how creepy and weird it is and
I munoz weird I love the like sidequest
structure a lot um like the cafe quest
is I love it cafe nod you yeah yeah but
the game in general i like its focus on
side quest like you were just saying it
there's only four main dungeons unless
you count like the end and whatnot but
unless you want to count like the gerudo
fortress the pirate fortress like this
but yeah everything looks way less
cooling is the bunny hood on just run
faster I for the bunny hood over Epona I
just all going I've had the the majora's
mask nandroid and I put the bunny ears
on him on purpose nice like it yeah as
much as I would love to talk about Zelda
for like another hour some more I did
wanna get on to other Nintendo
franchises I guess Mario's an obvious
one my love is what about a Odyssey what
do you think about odyssey being set on
the switch in like a semi real New York
City Dock city new dog city but don't
get dunno I feel really weird about this
game I don't feel as good as a lot of
people seem to I mean I don't want to
say that I feel super positive I'm not
down on it I just I have no idea what to
expect from it like how how we're over
on Bleecker there's a short Italian man
running around throwing the sentient had
at people I don't just go back to the
Mushroom Kingdom like what is this what
are you doing yeah he actually there's a
question mark on the cross street
crossing sign that street was called
expresso street and I just noticed that
for the first time oh dang
espresso or express it said expresso I
wasn't mispronouncing it I jumps off I
do like the idea of Mario navigating an
environment like this yeah I'm just
curious how the hell it's gonna make
sense in context of the world that he
exists but it's not like waka melee now
uh yeah yeah what do you uh what's your
favorite Mario game Pete yeah it's it's
either it's it's super mario world okay
it has to be i mean i think i really
like three like a lot of people to the
american version of two is certainly
different in quirky and obviously 64 and
you know i mean there's so many good
mario games super mario world is just
the one that i can instantly put in and
get into right away and have a hard time
stop playing yeah you have one I do not
have a favorite no I just I like that
guy's for a marked answer is there's no
favorite there's yeah mario 64 is like
the nostalgia one for me cuz I'm very
young but yeah yeah I grew up in the n64
and mario 64 is when my first games I
beat by myself do you like Yoshi's
Island I don't know if here she's I but
your sounds really good i like you ever
talk are you knocking me no I'm my poor
baby my baby Maury you clarify next time
please cuz I just got really offense and
very similar to him yeah it's true just
do a cosplay oh god all right what about
Star Fox its last outing was not the
best Starbucks is your own you reviewed
it would you think of it he loved it it
did I liked it better at the end than I
did at the beginning but it missed the
mark Star Fox zero and sorry Star Fox 64
on 3ds is the best starfox game hands
down they ported that game and it'll put
a lot of love into like brushing it up
and I'd love to see Nintendo revisit
that series but I also would be okay if
they never touched it again okay because
i don't i don't think okay I'm for this
way if Miyamoto's in control of the
series I don't want him to make another
starfox game because he is admittedly
hell-bent on you know introducing new
ideas and changing things he doesn't
want to do the same thing over and over
which I cannot blame him but that's what
people want from Star Fox they want an
experience that feels familiar that just
has different
challenges in a new setting and new
events I think most starfox fans will
agree 10 0 64 got it right everything
else is not quite there and of course
the peak was starfox adventures Ben
Howard this morning was telling me how
much he loves a game I like that game
it's one of my I think it's under
appreciated did you replace star fox
assault yes Namco made that was right
that was the next one after adventures
yeah yeah I did play it that was more
like a rogue squadron ish game wasn't it
yeah I don't know did you like it I
didn't play a whole lot of it cuz you
can go into third person on foot yeah I
was weird yeah um do you did are you a
star fox man Kelly no I don't know a lot
of us for a fun I played a little bit of
64 64 is great uh and then a bunch of
people are John Smith just goes Metroid
so I guess that's good a sangwich yeah
let's do not Smith on youtube if that's
his real name beside met roi ah yeah
that is the one that keeps getting
brought up for throughout the wii u
lifecycle and now the switch coming out
we were wondering when is metroid gonna
come back if it is because federation
force on the 3ds was not too promising
this is kind of falling into the same
issue that i described just a second ago
right we're nintendo really wants to do
new things with the franchise's they
have zelda is kind of an exception but
also it falls into line because breath
of the wild is this sort of new open
world experience but it's also a return
to form it's kind of similar to the
first game in some ways from metroid
people want the quote-unquote
Metroidvania or as i prefer castle roid
and so like a weird steroids I know I'm
good there are so many games that make
that style now so could nintendo really
make another they justify investing in
another game is just gonna follow in the
footsteps of the games that followed in
the footsteps of its game mm-hm you know
what i mean like that might be just too
redundant for them it's gonna start
using its like the people that followed
it as inspiration now is that even like
a viable thing to do so i mean i would
argue that yes it is i think because the
gameplay is one portion of metroid or
sure to state the structure of the game
but the gameplay itself is important and
it's tied to samis directly and samus is
a character that people really like she
was not handled appropriately in other m
yeah so I think Metroid Prime series is
great that handled her really well but I
think people need a new metroid games
are really just like honing on the fat
that samus is a [ __ ] badass and she
isn't an adventure that you all want so
I just play play to your dear fans
requests Nintendo that's the only thing
I can that's the advice they need and
just need to like follow through on that
I might be in the minority here but I
would actually rather see a more Metroid
Prime ish Metroid I would be happy with
another one as well yeah that's what I
was missing I think just super metroid
is like you mentioned like I don't think
you're gonna get better than super metra
in that style of game no but I mean
Metroid Prime even kind of you know it
it peaked in the first game I thought
like I felt like a Kanye was diminishing
with every new release I like corruption
more than echoes I think echo is this
the one that people didn't like as much
because of the whole like dark shadow
light players actually kind of a
stressful game I like corruption a lot
though but yeah i agree much i prime i
think it's the best one it's kind of
like a metal gear solid I like Metal
Gear Solid less as they go on mmm except
for I like five lot there's nothing to
do the nintendo place of tangent how
dare you yeah but anyway metroid prime
would be fantastic what are the
franchise's there's a lot of intent of
french can I talk about animal crossing
nail oh yeah you want to talk about
animal crossing I do oh sweet yes
message on YouTube just gave you the
perfect is that you do have your phone
on the table oh yeah I'm just tired I'm
also the person who asked about
undertale which it would totally not
come to the switch because it requires
pc hardware anyway oh so somebody an
animal crossing so as if people haven't
tried to already animal crossing is
basically just a game full of chores um
but what I like about it is it's it's
one of my like de-escalating my anxiety
games all you just check on it for 15
minutes a day and you're slowly building
up to something really nice like you can
build up a really beautiful town or if
you want to have as much money as as
humanly possible and so it's it's like a
slow burn rewarding like feedback system
of a game it's really it's it's unique
in that way and I really enjoy it for
that I didn't like city folk anhui I
think it's pretty good on handheld I
loved wild world i think i played wild
world every day for two years straight
mmm like a big problem and then when
news came out i lost my mind
so um and then I lost my safe and in
that now I haven't played it and I'm
really sad never played a minute of any
animal crossing game oh great I played
the original on gamecube and it I
couldn't get into it too much but what I
do love about the series is that these
it's like your town is persistent so if
you boot up your gamecube save now your
town is in shambles noise depressed
nothing is good because you haven't
played it in ten years it's on fire but
hates you I think that's a really cool
idea come back in the towns for Pete
Brown that's a name I haven't heard in a
long time yeah I'm dead if I didn't have
as many games to play as I do i my whole
plan is to get it on my japanese
language 3ds because it has the footy
gonna like the readings written above
all the kanji so it's really good for
learning kanji Oh was basically it'll
take a word spelled out in one alphabet
but then give you this succinct but
harder to learn representation from a
different alphabet love that word so
it's like sounds to of pages uh kids
don't know can't like know all the kanji
I think you need to know 3,000 to be
fluent or something it's a lot um but
yeah I think the main selling point for
me is that it is slowly rewarding like
the the best part is I can come back to
my town there's an ordinance because
you're the mayor in new leaf and so you
can be like oh yeah the flowers will
never die in my town make it so and then
you come back in your town still
beautiful and it just it fills me with
so much joy I just and then the animals
are your friends don't talk to Justin
hey wall you guys will just lose the
entire day talking about animal crossing
all he ever talks about it's true that
and P cross yes oh oh man don't even get
me started geez did you play pokemon
know uh oh man what did we miss any I
mean we missed a bunch but those ones
want to talk about any others I'm touch
on we didn't I do want to say how
excited I am for mario kart 8 to look
yeah cuz they're adding a bunch of stuff
and they're adding two items like in
Double Dash um which every Double Dash
is always everyone's favorite yeah it is
so um yeah the gamecube mario kart game
if you are not familiar but so they're
adding a bunch of new features and
mario kart is like the one game that i
would challenge anyone to I'll get very
aggressive um so I'm excited for that I
want to see new pilot wings yeah people
ever mentioning that too I didn't love
than one on 64 or the weird one like
pilotwings resort in 3ds but the
original Super Nintendo one was
pitch-perfect I think yeah get it [ __ ]
play Jesus is that it was y'all perfect
oh but wish but with the new controls I
think you could integrate like that
weird rumble feature pretty well to like
mimic the feeling of like rudders or
engines failing you like different stuff
like that I'm grasping at straws here
but uh there's a bunch of people yacht
subbu and the YouTube chat is one of a
few people saying Advance Wars your play
advance oh yeah engine systems the
company the studio behind Fire Emblem
games they made advance wars and those
games were really solid firing them like
sort of has supplanted it but I think
there's definitely room and people are
making homogeneous to that series now
which says it's about time intendo funds
another one of those I'd look that's a
good call I was gonna say I liked I did
not play fates yet still but i liked
awakening a lot I wasn't I'm not too
psyched for fire among warriors yeah I
like man I've thought Hyrule warriors is
fun for like a day yeah I I was really
into warriors games when I was in high
school and so I felt like oh I'm the i
am the exact market for Fire Emblem
warriors I still have to play fates
though yeah do both of them yeah 3 it
there's three all three of them so I
meant just provisions yeah okay cool so
yeah obviously there's a lot of antennal
franchise we did not touch on it's not
just intento anymore but the 20th
anniversary of symphony the Knights
coming up I know there have been
Castlevania games on antenna platforms
before since the Unites one of my
favorite games to talk about Castlevania
extensively maybe next month for the
20th anniversary of Cynthia tonight but
anyway if you guys have any franchise we
you want to talk about leaving the chat
right now try to call it out but also in
the comments below if your watch on
youtube or on gamespot and feel free to
tweet any one of us tell us why we
should have talked about uh I don't know
p cross more yeah yeah or balloon fight
more a balloon fight or Nintendo land
[Music]